le jeu de société l'un des loisirs
préférés des français
on va jouer tous ensemble sur les mêmes
mots on cache la première carte d'un
retour au hasard si ce sera elle
le premier jour pourrait par exemple
poser en se disant on va créer lecture
lecteurs au moment où vous posez une
carte il faut toujours penser à un mot
qui commence par les lettres qui sont
sur la table mais pour certains cela
représente beaucoup de travail et
d'espérance
kara et yoann viennent de créer un jeu
de lettres destinées à toute la famille
tous leurs temps libres y passe ses deux
amis d'enfance dijonnais écument les
festivals partout en france pour le
faire découvrir
l'opération séduction fonctionne plutôt
bien
déjà mille boîtes vendues en l'espace de
quatre mois voir que les gens s'amusent
avec quelque chose qu'on a créé de a à z
vraiment on est parti de rien on est
parti d'un bout de papier à écrire des
idées jusqu'à la boîte final c'est une
formation qui a été extraordinaire
passer par la case départ et toucher 20
milles ça c'est au monopoly dans la
vraie vie ce sont les deux copains qui
ont investi 20 mille euros pour la
sortie de leur jeu ils sont encore loin
d'être rentrés dans leurs frais mais
kara et yoann voit grand ils ont
également monté leur maison d'édition
dans leurs cartons une quinzaine d'
idées de jeux dont certaines sont déjà
au stade du prototype
c'est une passion on va dire qu'on a
voulu
monté en société puisque oui on a nos
jobs respectifs
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui on peut
pas se payer avec un seul jeu ça c'est
si ça fait un énorme carton et on s'est
même pas 5% des jeux qui sortent par an
mais avoir moi donc temps on veut que
les bénéfices des premiers jeux nous
servent à créer de nouveaux jeux pour
qu'on puisse avoir le plus grand
catalogue possible pour ce que pour que
derrière où on puisse voilà en vivre
on aimerait un jour en vivre en france
le marché du jeu de société explose
depuis dix ans il a dépassé le cercle
des enfants et des initiés mais les
auteurs sont les moins bien rémunérés
seulement 2% du prix d'une boîte monter
sa maison d'édition peut donc se révéler
intéressant encore faut-il parvenir à
faire sa place dans un secteur dominé
par une poignée de géants historiques et
très concurrentielles 900 à 1000 jeu
sort chaque année en france
et tous ne trouvent pas leur public
belleneuve près de dijon
derrière la façade de cette bâtisse une
maison d'édition qui a généré huit cent
cinquante mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires l'an dernier l'entreprise a
édité 12 jeux dont certains se sont
écoulés à 30000 exemplaires non
seulement en france mais aussi en europe
au japon ou encore au canada
un succès bâti là encore par une bande
de copains passionnés et bénévoles qui
crée un jeu sur le thème des zombies
cinq ans plus tard l'entreprise compte
cinq salariés et jouit d'une belle
notoriété
il faut sortir de sa zone de confort
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas être trop
ambitieux mais faut être quand même
assez ambitieux pour essayer de de faire
des choses qui n'ont pas été vues avant
un petit peu bousculer les lignes pour
sortir du lot tout simplement si la
france compte une centaine de maisons
d'édition elles sont peu nombreuses à
tirer leur épingle du jeu
pourtant le marché est juteux il peser
en 2010 7 475 millions d'euros
[Musique]